[Music]
do
[Music]
game development's so easy animations
no problem
it's all it's all pretty easy around
here you know
living here on easy street just
programming away
there's never a wasted day here
every day we progress steadily
[Music]
errors are very rare occurrence
happening at most once every other day
for the most part
everything just worked
work i was gonna say works perfectly
um
that's probably just a small glitch
really you know
and we got a math function wrong flip
the symbol
[Music]
um
yeah that's
that's that's fine
maybe we'll just fix it later or
something
why don't we just run all the tests
we'll see how the tests go you know and
if like all the tests work then
uh we're fine defaulting it looks good
fireplace room looks good looks better
than last time
lighting tests not too shabby
don't fix the
well
yeah
with the sunlight moving around you can
see the shadows moving
[Music]
wow
reusing model resources looks like where
you got a success here
let's uh continue
uh-oh
that's not supposed to be like that
okay that's better
these two seem to be animating okay
this guy is just uh not at all
he's supposed to be having an idol
animation not sure why he's broken
i think the shadows are a little too
intense
let's do something like this
okay so animations are a little broken
skybox is nothing changed here
looks good
sound effects nothing changed there
either
stenciling on the animated guy looks
okay
this looks fine
okay so apparently just some animation
bugs let's see if those were here
previously so let's try a previous
version with that same animation
we're going to go all the way back to
december 1st
before i messed with any of the
animations this was
a long time ago
let's uh
okay maybe we gotta let's try this
[Music]
oh this was before the rename even
okay okay
where's the models here we go
we have a paladin we set a kick
or a walk let's change this
to our new guy
let's take in this vanguard guy
he's the broken one and let's put it in
here
and let's just paste this in and let's
give this project a run
and see if he works
all right so we hit play and it looks
like we got some breakpoints here
i failed to load path here
uh what happened
let's go up the stack frame and take a
look oh my mouse is locked
awkwardly
see if we can get out of this now
yeah i literally can't move my mouse
above this point
yeah it's like stuck in the window
that's not even here okay
great great programming there we go
okay so
we just want to fix this path
maybe it's this one
probably let's just
vomit it out
all right let's go
okay here we go
he's currently set to none
okay so
now
let's go check out this guy
and if we click walk he should walk
okay we got a break point there let's
ignore that keep going oh we got a
something
some kind of error
[Music]
let's try that again
and this time let's press kick
some kind of error okay what happened
here so this guy might be broken because
this used to work
ah these animations need fixed if
they're gonna work properly some of them
do some of them don't think i'm going to
do my best to not spend a ton of time on
it and yet still fix it somehow
famous last words for us programmers so
anyway back to the latest version
of ancient archer we go
check out this one
here we go one of my stash and reapply
nothing i hope
all right well applying a few minor
fixes we can uh stitch up some of these
errors real quick like i'll use my
add camera method that automatically
makes it
full screen and where the cameras stick
to full screen
rather than a smaller viewport because
yeah you can make cameras with different
viewports pretty standard thing
great for mirrors and such
this looks overall okay except for that
vanguard but i'm convinced that it's
just a broken model in animation so
maybe we'll test it somewhere else like
unreal or unity to see how it does over
there
go ahead and give unreal 5.02 a launch
and we'll see what we can do with this
model
[Music]
back to my engine here and just run a
little test
[Music]
see what happens
[Music]
essentially i'm doing the same thing
i'm adding the model
setting the animation it's actually
doing everything fine it's just not
transformed correctly
so what did we miss like he's actually
doing a little animation which is you
know the sign that the animation is
actually loading but something about the
phones are not correct here
i don't know why i've been looking at it
looking at it
and that is my life right now apparently
the music is very loud all right but uh
yeah just to close it up here's the repo
and if you want to check it out and see
all the changes you can go click on it
and just see the changes that's probably
the easiest way
to do it
[Music]
yeah that's now we're getting into weird
good details and how to do that but
essentially it's all public record of
how this is going and if you want to
support this project
go give a star on github and if you're
smart about this kind of stuff you can
also help me fix stuff because
wow is it difficult
and if you really want to go the extra
mile you can also
[Music]
sponsor me on either patreon or one of
the other sites github as well for code
stuff
twitch if you got
prime and just wanna you know help there
etc thanks for watching guys
see in the next one matt out
[Music]
you